this is a story that I haven't seen a
lot of people talk about but
it's a it's a really good sign for the
culture and the sign is that Burning Man
ticket prices are collapsing you know
burning man if you have never been you
if you're listening to the show you very
likely have never been to burning man
maybe you have but you probably know
some big lib or hippie who has been
burning man is this weird ritual every
year where people go out to the desert
like a bazillion people go to the desert
and they do a bunch of drugs and they
have sex with a lot of people and they
move around like weirdo hippies and they
worship this this Burning Idol
and people think of it as an artistic
event you know man or it's like kind of
a cultural it's like a fun like weird
cultural thing well it was a it was a
really big deal and now the tickets are
collapsing tickets
face value or 575 bucks and yet now
they're selling for as low as 139 bucks
parking passes used to be 150 now
they're being marked down to 105 bucks
we've never seen anything like this
what's going on is it an artistic shift
no it's not because that people don't
like the music as much anymore is it a
cultural shift
not exactly
it's a religious shift because
Burning Man is a religious ritual
they literally worship a burning Idol
okay there's no there is virtually no
difference between what the hippies do
at Burning Man and what the apostate
perfidious Israelites did in the desert
when Moses went up the mountain and left
them alone to their own devices and they
started having all sorts of bacchanals
and worshiping a golden calf
there is virtually no difference
and forget about the Israelites for a
second shows you that even the most
serious monotheistic God's chosen people
can be so faithless but virtually every
Pagan Society throughout all of history
throughout the Hellenic world and
throughout the the uncivilized world too
this is what they do
they do a bunch of drugs and they have a
bunch of orgies and they worship
gigantic Idols that's what they do and
that's what they were doing here at
Burning Man and I think people just got
sick of it because religious fads come
and go false gods come and go
this is the wisdom of Bishop Fulton
Sheen who says that if you marry
yourself to the spirit of the world
you'll find the spirit of the age rather
you'll find yourself a widow in the next
so the Burning Man the false Burning Man
God
seems to be passing away there are other
false gods they're cropping up these
same weirdo new agey hippies are going
to go do some other bizarre ritual
that's going to involve a lot of drugs
and a lot of orgies not a lot of bizarre
activity but it's not going to be this
one this one's not going to endure only
true religion endures this is the line
of Hillary belloch who says the way that
he has to take it on faith that the
Catholic church is real that's divinely
instituted but if you don't believe it
the proof of its Divine institution is
that no other organization conducted
with such Navy imbecility would have
lasted a fortnight much less 2 000 years
a lot longer
than burning man right now go to
geniusell.com Knowles what do you see
when you look in the mirror do you see
dark spots well they're not going to go
away on their own you need help from
geniusell's Dark Spot Corrector here
just in time for the summer and for the
fall and for the winter all year round
the Dark Spot Corrector has not won but
three Cutting Edge ingredients goes to
work fast on sunspots dark spots liver
spots even old discoloration both on
your face and hands you will be amazed
at how quickly you see results you can
now enjoy summer beach Sun barbecues
without embarrassing spots with genuine
cell you will see the results or your
money back no questions asked go to
genucel.com Knowles right now get your
dark spot corrector with the new genius
almost popular package and say goodbye
to those pesky spots tomorrow they're
offering free shipping free returns and
the best luxury skincare you've ever
used all for seventy seven zero percent
off all orders will also include a
mystery luxury gift while supplies last
genucel dot com slash Knowles Rhonda
Santos who's still the number two guy in
the race got in a little bit of trouble
over the weekend because he had an
interview with Will Witt arpel will Whit
formerly of Prager unit of the Florida
standard in which DeSantis described
Trump voters as listless vessels
we have a strand in our in our party
that views
supporting Trump as whether you are
um a rhino or not and so you could be
the most conservative person since
sliced bread unless you're kissing his
rear end they will somehow call you a
rhino so it's been totally detached from
principle and what you actually believe
in results and it's more about you know
just what faction you happen to do so
there'll be people who are huge Trump
supporters like in Congress who have
like incredibly liberal left-wing
records that that's really just
atrocious and yet they're viewed as by
by some of these folks as like as like
really really good then you have other
people you know like a congressman chip
Roy who's endorsed me Congressman Thomas
Massey these guys have records of
principal fighting the swamp that are
second to none and yet they will be
attacked by some of these people and and
called rhinos so it's just been totally
detached from any type of substance and
ultimately but let's pause it right
there okay he has more to say which is
important but as for what the governor
said up till that point he's basically
right his observation is right
that there are very liberal republicans
in Congress who because they support
Trump
get praise and adulation from the more
conservative elements of the GOP base
well that seems crazy doesn't it whereas
you get a chip Roy or you get a Thomas
Massey or other people who are have
pretty decent Bona fides as right
Wingers Rock ribbed people and they get
attacked by the more conservative
wing of the GOP and they get lumped in
with the more liberal wing of the GOP
and it's all based on whether or not you
support Trump
that is more indicative of whether
you're considered a hard right winger or
a squishy liberal type then one's voting
record or the statements that one makes
on various policy issues that part is
true now where DeSantis I think goes
wrong is in his explanation of this a
movement can't be about the personality
of one individual the movement has got
to be about what are you trying to
achieve on behalf of the American people
and that's got to be based in principle
because if you're not rooted in
principle uh if all we are is listless
vessels it's just supposed to follow you
know whatever happens to come down the
pike on Truth social every morning that
that's not going to be a durable
movement
wood that it were so simple Governor
would that it were so simple but first
of all
not a not a good idea to insult the
primary base and the way he does it here
it's not as bad as the deplorables
comment as some people are suggesting it
was it's not as bad as the bitter
clinger's argument in fact DeSantis is
lumping himself in there he's saying
look if we all do this we can serve this
be Republicans then we're going to be
listless vessels and we're not going to
do very well okay fair enough
the thing that he gets wrong here is
that politics is not just about the
message it's also about the messenger
this gets back to a basic observation
from the Canadian Communications
theorist Marshall mcluhan
the medium is the message
the medium is the message in politics
especially that's the case because we're
electing men we're not just electing
robots we're not just electing blank
slates or we're not just electing five
bullet point manifestos on the back of a
napkin we're electing living breathing
men with flesh and blood who walk around
and who say things and who do have
personalities
politics is largely about personality
and a problem for desantises because
he's the anti-trump candidate he's
attracted a lot of support from the
squishy liberal side of the party I
don't think DeSantis has particular
affection for the squishy liberal side
of the party over the conservative side
but that's just the way these sort of
things shake out you think about if you
only voted on issues let's say you were
an abortion
voter you're purely pro-life that's the
only issue you cared about
you'd probably vote for Mike Pence Mike
Pence has a very very consistent record
of being pro-life much more so than
Donald Trump
and Donald Trump has spoken favorably of
abortion rights rights quote unquote in
his career
and yet Trump got more done
on abortion than Mike Pence did Mike
Pence was part of that because he was
the vice president of the administration
but you don't just vote on issues you
vote on the whole thing and the reason
the personality matters is because
Donald Trump is viewed by the liberal
establishment as a wrench into the
system that's why they're Prosecuting
him over nothing that's why they're
making up these ridiculous excuses to
prosecute him because the very fact of
electing this guy was such a middle
finger to the system in 2016 that they
can't take it anymore and so that's why
they tried to undermine his
administration based on BS that they
just didn't fabricated out of whole
cloth and that's why they're they're
trying to put it into an orange jumpsuit
now
so it's a little bit like the facts
don't care about your feelings thing
that's it's true that facts don't care
about your feelings exactly but politics
largely cares about your feelings and
that's why DeSantis though he's got a
great record and though he's got a great
program he's probably got a very
coherent political Vision he is going to
have to inspire personal loyalty based
on his personality if he wants to take
the number one spot in the race it's as
simple as that what a great clip that
was huh wasn't that good well if you
want more of it you got to subscribe to
the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time